okay so we de-energized uh the mount
charleston area at approximately 6 45
this morning that was based off of a
concern that the storm system that's
moving through the spring mountains
is bringing with it elevated winds we
were seeing winds in the kyle canyon
area
of about 65 miles an hour and up on the
angel peak area where a lot of the lines
that feed into mount charleston are we
were seeing uh wind gusts in excess of
75 miles an hour so at those elevated
wind speeds
we definitely meet our psalm criteria
for proactive de-energization and so
that's why we de-energized the mountain
this morning we've been tracking this
weather system for the past several days
in the past 36 hours we really saw a
change in the weather forecast an
increase in the forecasted wind gusts
specifically
and so that's why yesterday we declared
a psalm warning uh once we realized that
that forecast was starting to change uh
for the worse
specifically with the wind gusts
so right now we are de-energized we
expect wind gusts to peak somewhere
between 1 pm and 5 pm today
and then depending on when those wind
gusts start to subside we will start the
re-energization of the mountain
prior to re-energization we have to
conduct a patrol
on uh all of our facilities up in the
mount charleston area so if the winds do
not subside by say five or six tonight
we will have to keep the power off
overnight at mount charleston because we
have to conduct those inspections during
daylight hours one so that we can
actually see the facilities but two
to ensure the safety of our crews so we
have a a full team up there right now
that continues to monitor the weather
real time and as soon as this weather
event subsides we will begin that
proactive re-energization process either
tonight if uh if
the weather allows or tomorrow morning